символічна фото зроблено з чим школі
самого ну і ви означало жити а висячи на
твіттері що у студента старий юрія
поправка even пройшов на майдан
протестувати і про ти рудим у януковича
а потім розум з друзям і поїхав уже
окупований слов'янськ
а цього ти міс цілих на видавати
українці хлопці не враховували що на
сході в жид справжній вина і по але я
звірять жорстокість лікувальний розум потрапила
у підлозі та їх 2 там шматок від овалу і там
такі рани гвинті абразії тобто я так
розумієш Іван III кинути перфоратором в
його справи поправкою то йогу друга
юрія дюковського зайшли за кілька днів fury
честі у слов'янському районі разом і
стилом депутатів гулівського миск раді
володимира рибалки та кого quit не 2014
th педалі та жорстокому туртурро представив
випробувавши 100 новий the proper україни
наводили за куплену народиш
адміністрації у всіх трьох визнала та
героєм та
небесної сотні мене до сильним можемо з
прийнятим не даєте шауро
тут там накачаєте і виникла така
ідея шипаючи касі
віковічний то я їх не їм я знаходиться
таких подібних людей з такою загину їм
це і я нехай їх віце розпочатим юрій
поправкам реостати юристом і борід зник
корупцію тому граматика організації
пологи на героїв сотню новин
і transparency international силу руку
на грудях ловить знакове ім'я юрія
поправкою на та фарбуючих регіональних
бурців скрутки доступну руку
значить чед-3 на йому найкращих героїв
небесної сотні на згадку про назарову то
краще премія для студентів mit сил
миротворці рид знаку і ми не вуст і могло
дню до
або знаку для паралімпійців і мені двоє
travaux та мало в рамках
мені stars as with та науки там культури
чим малаги спорту німа і кістка така
програми до душі нового про великих з
такі знаки, на жаль, держави у нас за раз
не займається цим же виглядом ходить на
задній план зовсім крім ну мужики
караоке ярослава поправках
ще доступним уроку кроччі борці з
корупцією україни снів відривають вигляд
знаку над 6 її сина для неї з свої видно
накладання влади пробити анку
так ви 100 до кінця кримінальні справи
права майдану лютий